hey guys it is the 18th of August today
my name is just McDonald and here's a
bunch of things that mattered in gaming
today in use of sketchy things that are
seriously sketchy a console has launched
on a Chinese crowdfunding website which
looks a suspiciously similar to a ps4
it's certainly not the first time we've
seen a manufacturer rip up a well-known
brand the console is called the yay and
yes that is uncomfortably similar to the
recently razer acquired console booyah
apparently it's a tad more powerful the
leader yeah but what is particularly
concerning is that the shell looks like
a ps4 while the controller looks almost
exactly like the Xbox one controller the
Android based console is being developed
by a company in Shenzhen who are asking
for 15 grand to fund the project they
plan to charge the equivalent of 70 US
bucks for the not ps4 and the not Xbox
one controller if that's not hilarious
enough reportedly the company behind the
project spent more than a year crafting
the consoles port unique design no word
yet on whether a stretch goal may
include a not Wii U gamepad the music
should surprise nobody Rainbow six siege
has been delayed thus ending the
two-week drought in games being delayed
although to be honest it's more of an
eight-hour drought if we're including
the Vita version of volume initially
expected to land in October the release
date for Rainbow six siege has been
shifted to December 1st of this year in
a blog post Ubisoft explained this
wasn't an easy decision but based on the
feedback we've received and based on our
own internal tests we felt there are
adjustments and improvements we can make
including improving the co-op experience
across all game modes weapon and gadget
balancing as well as menu and interface
navigation the game's closed beta will
commence as planned on September 24 and
you be upset feedback from this in
addition to the extra Jeff time will
result in a test
experience at launch and finally Xbox
executor sooner de said that the Xbox
one has a lot more going on than the ps4
if you're wondering what that is exactly
I'm about to tell you Sinhala told games
industry international that things like
cross play and cross by with PC as well
as backwards compatibility are giving
Xbox one the upper hand digging into the
benefits of cross play he explained you
should be able to play what you love and
play together regardless of what device
you're playing on it's about connecting
people it's a really unique value that
only we can alter adding we're doing
things that can't be done on any other
console meanwhile five million rocket
League players on ps4 and PC are playing
against each other happily let me know
down in that comment section if you
prefer the features on Xbox one or ps4
and why you can head to GameSpot or
we've got stories on alien 5 and fallout
shelter ads on tinder those are all the
gaming tidbits I have the you today let
me know what you cared about and I will
catch you again on Wednesday
[Music]